when you were speaking near the
beginning of this answer you were saying
that lunacy is a step along the path now
I just want to make clear so were you
saying that are you saying like look do
not go insane go seek help if you're
feeling
well uh I was speaking in a in a sort of
room an esoteric letter though I think
uh it was a little Loosely that I was
speaking because there are two kinds of
lunacy in principle there's the ordinary
kind of lunacy which arises from a lack
of intelligence
and that's what our clinical
psychologists know about
but there's another kind of apparent
lunacy which is simply wisdom Beyond an
ordinary human level
when the when your wisdom exceeds a
certain plane
uh humano of expressing it can vary
readily be seen as lunacy
and in the history of
human religions I think you can in just
about every religion point to actual
historic figures
which had that kind of lunacy so here's
where I disagree with Jung Carl Jung or
maybe it's more that I don't know so
Carl Jung had a phrase that beware of
undeserved wisdom and then you express
the sentiment that there's wisdom and if
you're not ready for it it's beyond your
level it can be seen as lunacy so I
don't know if what people attain when
they crack or they have psychotic
episodes and so on is indeed wisdom just
they weren't ready for it I was speaking
to John verake who you spoke to and John
verbaki says that there's something
that's incorrect if it's provoking such
fear or anxiety there's something that's
misframed so I don't know if it's as
simple as if truth is a ball and you can
grab it but you're not ready for it I
think somehow if you're not ready for it
you grabbed something wrong or it's not
as simple as the grabbing of a ball like
a true ball and then it hurts you in
some way
but I think
there are both we must recognize that
bosses think these things are real on
the one hand
you have uh people who
for example try to ascend in an
intellectual spiritual way and
incidentally if you do this without a
guru without somebody who is really a
master and is guiding you you're doing
something that's very risky I think this
is what happened to Nature I think
nature was by Nature a very very
brilliant and very very deep man who as
it were by his
by his DNA was seeking God
but in the European culture of his day
there was no one who could even
understand nature
there were very few figures in the
Europe of that time in the
german-speaking world who had any real
conception I think one of the few people
who broke out of that menu was good
there I think he was one of the few but
Gerta himself
was not clear about everything but in in
good I see a man who was Way Way Beyond
the level of his day
nature was I think by Nature equally
deep
but somehow other
he
he got off to the deep end
if if nature had had a proper Guru I
think we would now know him as a great
man
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy